foreign
I hope you're doing well and staying
safe I welcome you all to yet another
interesting tutorial I hope my audio is
fine and the screen is clearly visible
if you guys are facing any issues let us
know in the comment section below and
we'll try to fix it as soon as possible
in today's session we'll be going
through nosql database and we'll
understand what exactly our nosql
database how they came into existence
why we use them and how they are
different from traditional relational
databases
let us just wait for another two minutes
so that rest of the people will also
join the session in the meantime guys I
would like to update that we have
regular updates on multiple Technologies
on our channel so if you are a tech geek
and love watching Tech videos consider
getting subscribed to our Channel simply
code to stay updated with all the latest
Technologies and also hit the Bell icon
to never miss an update from us
alright as you all know we are living in
the era of Big Data where massive
volumes of data are generated per second
worldwide so handling and storing these
huge chunks of data is pivotal are
Paramount for all the companies around
the world traditionally relational
databases were used to store this data
prior to when the internet came into
existence now in the early 1990s the
internet gained extreme popularity and
the relational databases could not keep
up with the flow of information and data
demanded by the users as well as the
large variety of data types that
occurred from this Evolution this led to
the development of non-relational
databases often referred to as no SQL
the not only SQL are commonly known as
nosql databases is an approach to data
management and database design that may
be useful for large sets of distributed
data and unstructured data it basically
consists of collection of Technologies
and architecture that seek to address
Big Data performance and scalability
issues that relational databases cannot
address so this database is used when
businesses and Enterprises require
access to an analysis of large amounts
of unstructured data now these
unstructured data can be of any type it
can be a text file it can be an image or
video and others that are stored across
multiple servers so it is important that
we understand how this nosql databases
work so in today's session we'll be
going through all the concepts that are
needed to understand what nosql
databases are and how it they exactly
work so without any further delay let us
jump straight into today's topic
firstly let us go to the agenda for
today's session we'll start the tutorial
by understanding what is SQL and then
we'll look at why we use SQL and after
that we'll understand what is nosql
database and then we'll understand why
we use nosql up next we'll understand
how to use nosql and how exactly it
works and then we'll look at some
different types of nosql databases and
after that we'll have a detailed
comparison between SQL and osql database
and finally we'll conclude the session
by understanding some advantages and
disadvantages of using nosql and will
also look when to use SQL as well as
nosql so without any further delay let's
dive straight into today's topic on SQL
versus nosql firstly let us understand
what is SQL SQL as it stand is defined
as structure query language is basically
a standardized programming language that
is used to manage databases and it
performs various operations on data in
them initially created in 1970s SQL is
widely used by many companies and
Technologies nowadays
SQL is used for modifying database
tables and index structures it is also
used in adding updating and deleting
rows of data it is also used to retrieve
subsets of information from within the
database management system
now SQL is used to perform various
actions such as to insert data to update
data modify and delete the data in the
database as well
now when we talk about SQL it is
important that we talk about relational
database systems as well a relational
database system or RDM rdbms is a
database system that stores and fetches
data in the form of table that is in the
form of rows and columns tables are used
to store data and relational databases
about related objects each column
contains attributes of data whereas each
row holds a record of unique data known
as a key which helps in making
relationship between different data
points that is present in different
table which makes us easy to understand
now these relational databases or rdbms
are managed using SQL language
to perform various operations therefore
SQL codes are used to retrieve
information from these relational
databases by doing various interactive
operations like using join create
truncate delete alter and Etc
let us now look at some popular SQL
databases some popular SQL databases
that are available are MySQL Oracle
database Microsoft SQL
server sqlite and postgre SQL
now that we have understood what is SQL
let us now understand what is non SQL
that is no SQL sorry no SQL database is
a non-relational database management
system that does not require a fixed
schema that is the data is stored is not
stored in the form of tables in nosql
databases
basically it avoids any uh joining or
creating or scaling the databases in SQL
the major purpose of using a nosql
database is for distributed data storage
which is having high volumes of data
storage needs nosql is used for big data
and real-time web applications like for
example companies like Amazon Facebook
Google correct terabytes of users data
and every single day
so basically nosql database stands for
not only SQL or not SQL and it is
introduced in the year 1998 by Karl
Strauss a traditional rdbms uses SQL
syntax to store and retrieve data for
further insights now instead a nosql
database system encompasses a wide range
of database technologies that can store
structured semi-structured as well as
unstructured data
let us now understand why we use nosql
we use
hierarchical storage structure instead
of a table like structure
that means uh before relational
databases companies used a hierarchical
database system which with a tree-like
structure for database tables now these
early database Management Systems enable
users to organize large quantities of
data however they were complex often
required a particular application and in
a limited way which they could uncover
the data that is stored now these
limitations eventually led to the
development of relational database that
is the data that is stored in tables uh
so a skill provided an interface to
interact with relational data and
allowing the analyst to connect Tables
by merging on common fields But as time
passed the demand for faster and more
desperate usage of larger data sets
became increasingly more important for
emerging Technologies for e-commerce and
other big change for that nosql has
become the alternative for everyone
now another reason is it is now we have
constant addition of new features and
functions in the nosql database right
so that means like we know that
technology is being rapidly evolved and
huge enormous amounts of data has been
released on a daily basis and it's
important that we store this data and
access in a quick way now nosql is the
best database to use for large amounts
of data or for Ever Ever Changing data
sets it is also best use when you have
to have flexible data model or need that
don't fit into a relational model
and finally when if if you want that uh
there is no relationship between any
stored data and the field is not
important then you can use nosql as well
let us now look at some popular noise
scale databases some popular nosql
databases are mongodb Apache hbase
Cassandra redis neo4j and Etc
let us now look at some types of nosql
databases that are present
firstly we have document oriented the
document database typically stores
self-describing Json XML and piece on
documents they are similar to key value
stores but in this case a value is a
single document that stores all the data
to related to a specific key popular
fields in the document can be indexed to
provide faster interval without knowing
the key as well each document can have
same or different data structure
mongodb couchdb cloudant are some
examples of document based nosql
database next we have key value pair
database the data in this is stored like
a key value pairs key value pair data
stored in database in the form of a hash
table each key is unique in this case
the value stored may be an integer
string a binary object a Json object Etc
the key Value Store based database is
simplest database among all the data
databases in nosql database
redis coherents are examples of some key
Value Store databases
next we have column based or column
store database in nosql which is in this
the data stored in grouped columns
instead of rows every column values are
stored separately it delivers high
performance on aggregate functions like
count some Max minimum group of columns
are data stored in key spaces like
schema and rdbms key spaces contains
group of rows or columns
and hbase bigtable aquilmo are some
examples of column store databases
and finally we have graph oriented or
graph store databases data in this is
represented in the form of a directed
graph it consists of notes and edges
nodes represent an entity and any Edge
represents the relation between the two
nodes node H to be unique social
networks Logistics paytl data used uh
graphical storage database neo4j
infinite graph Orient DB flock DB are
examples of some graph storage database
next let us understand how exactly nosql
database works for that I am going to
take the example of mongodb database now
mongodb is based on the nosql document
store model in which data objects has
stored as separate documents inside a
collection instead of a traditional
column and row of a relational database
now uh mongodb groups data through
Collections and basically a collection
is simply a grouping of documents that
have a SIM or similar purpose a
collection acts similarly to a table in
a traditional SQL database however it
has a major difference a collection is
not enforced by a strict schema that is
it does not have any fixed schema at all
instead documents in a collection can
have slightly different structure from
another as needed this reduces the need
to break items in a document into
several different tables at as it is
often done in an SQL implementation now
coming to document a document is a
representation of a single entity of a
data in mongodb database a collection
consists of one or more related objects
major difference that exist between
mongodb and SQL is that in that
documents are different from rows row
data is flat with one column for each
value in the row however in mongodb
documents can contain embedded
sub-documents providing a much closer
inherent data model for your
applications now if I just have to map
what uh what are exactly and how it is
different from rdbms a collection in a
mongodb is equivalent to the tables in
rdbms and a document in mongodb is
equivalent to the rows in rdbms and
Fields in mongodb is equivalent to the
columns in rdbms
so this is how a document looks uh in a
mongodb as you can see this is similar
to a row in rdbms but we just have a
field and a value that is taken
separately in instead of a tape tabular
value
and another important thing to note note
here is that mongodb supports Dynamic
schema which means one document of a
collection can have a number of fields
while the other document can have less
or same number of fields that is if a
collection can have a four Fields while
other document can have only just two
fields which is basically not possible
in a relational database which does not
exist uh as it it does not support
because it needs a particular and a
fixed schema in that
let us now understand some differences
between the SQL and nosql firstly SQL is
a relational database and nosql is a
non-relational database that means SQL
databases are in the form of tables that
can contain rows and columns and they
have fixed logical schema design all the
data in SQL is arranged in tabular
format and it is well suited for complex
queries and on the other hand nosql
databases is a non-relational database
that means it does not store data in the
form of tables and contains Collections
and inside every collection there is a
document that contains the data of a
single entry we store this data is
stored in the form of a key value pair
unlike SQL where we store data under the
fixed schema
so as we discussed uh SQL has a fixed
schema design and structure and nosql
has a dynamic schema design and
structure
SQL can handle complex queries whereas
no SQL can handle large volumes of data
now SQL is vertically scalable
now uh SQL databases support vertical
scaling which means it improves a single
server by increasing Ram SSD or CPU in
vertical scaling we are restricted to a
single system and we can improve it as
much as we want till the Practical limit
whereas in nosql database we can do
horizontal scaling because they support
distributed computing or distributed
systems in horizontal scaling we can add
another node or computer for better
performance and we can add a number of
such servers or nodes as per a
requirement so as discussed we can add
as many as nodes as we want and this is
why we prefer nosql for high scalability
because there is no limit for scaling
and finally it follows acid properties
that is atomicity that means transaction
should be performed at once or it
shouldn't happen at all consistency that
means the state of a database should
remain consistent before and after the
transaction isolation that is one
traction one transaction shouldn't
affect another transaction and it
shouldn't and should be independent and
we lastly durability now successful
transaction should be reflected even if
there is any system failure whereas the
noise skill follows cap property
that is consistency availability and
partial tolerance
let us now discuss some advantages and
disadvantages of using nosql firstly let
us discuss about the advantages
nosql provides high performance and
scalability and it also has a lot of
availability and flexibility it is open
source and it is schema less as well
that is you can directly uh download the
nosql databases from the internet unlike
some commercial databases that are
available in the internet
while on the other hand there are some
disadvantages as well that is it is it
lacks the standardization that means it
does not have a fixed query uh in order
to retrieve data from the databases
which result in in consistency issues
and since it has all these consistency
issues and does not retrieve data
properly it it has a limited query
capabilities
so that brings us to the end of today's
session on SQL versus noise scale guys
so you might have a doubt that when you
need to use SQL and when we need to use
nosql now SQL is easiest to work with
relational databases that is it is
useful when you want to perform complex
queries using various operations like
join and Etc and if you want to perform
quick data storage and retrieval
operations you can use SQL whereas uh if
you want you can use nosql if you are
designing a distributed systems and if
you want a hierarchical storage
structure instead of a tabular like
structure also nosql gives you the
flexibility to create Dynamic structures
and and can add features as you as you
want
as also there is no asset properties
during the creation of any applications
while creating a
noise scale databases as well so in this
way you can use nosql and SQL as per
your requirement
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn YouTube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos turn it up and get certified
click here